In this section of our course, we will go through a hands-on exercise where we will
export the conformed mesh that is generated from a metahuman identity solve from the metahuman
identity asset window.
This exercise demonstrates one approach to fitting metahuman topology to a scanner sculpt
by using the conformed mesh to refit any details that were lost from the solve.
If you already fitted the metahuman head topology to your scanner sculpt using a metahuman preset,
you would skip these steps.
We will primarily work in Unreal Engine.
As we work through this exercise, you will note that this is broken down into a step-by-step
process that is found in your slide deck.
As we complete portions of the practical exercise, I will review the completed steps.
Now, let's jump into Unreal Engine and go through the steps of exporting the conformed
mesh from the metahuman identity asset window.
Inside of Unreal Engine, to get started, we would first need to go through the steps of
generating a metahuman identity that will be used for fitting metahuman topology to a
scan using the standard mesh to metahuman workflow.
Since we already went through those steps and generated one in the metahuman introduction
class, let's locate that metahuman identity asset.
Under the courses folder, in the folder named MEH11301, let's navigate to the course topics
folder.
In the folder named mesh to metahuman identity, it is located in the folder named EX for example.
The metahuman identity is named RCSCAN.
Let's double-click on this to open it.
Inside of here, the first step is to go down here to the command PROPT.
Then enter the command MHIDENITY EXPORT MESHES and the number 1 and press ENTER.
Now go up to the main toolbar and select metahuman identity solve.
What this does is it exports the metahuman identity conformed mesh.
Once this process completes, we can close this window.
The next step is to locate the exported conformed mesh which will be in the file explorer saved
folder of the Unreal Engine project.
To locate this easily, I'm going to go to the content folder and then right-click on
it and select SHOW AN EXPLORER.
This will open up the file explorer of our course project.
We want to navigate to the main project folder and then open up the SAVED folder.
Inside of here, at the bottom here, is an obj file named RCSCANED MESH.
This is the scanned mesh that was used for the solve.
In the folder named RCSCAN, which is the name of our metahuman identity, we will see
an obj file named CONFORMAL FACE MESH.
This is the metahuman identity conformed mesh that is of metahuman topology.
Now before we move on, let's do a quick review of the steps we just covered.
We just went through the process of exporting the conformed mesh from the metahuman identity
asset window.
Instead of manually fitting a metahuman preset to your scanner sculpt, you can simply use
the standard MESH to metahuman workflow to generate an initial metahuman identity.
The benefits of this is that you can align the metahuman identity with the headscan,
making it easier to transfer textures from the scanned data to the identity.
To get started, you will first create an initial metahuman identity by importing and preparing
the mesh.
Since this is an image-based solve, using a texture can help to track the facial features
better.
Next, create a metahuman identity asset and populate it.
Create and track a neutral pose and run the identity solve.
From there, you can enable and adjust additional trackers and spend a good amount of time on
the eyes and mouth to get a more precise solve.
Once you are finished, submit the template mesh to the metahuman backend.
To export the metahuman identity conformed mesh from the metahuman identity asset, in
the command prompt, enter, mh, identity, export meshes, and the number 1.
Once you hit enter, in the main toolbar, select metahuman identity solve.
Next, locate the conformed mesh.
To locate the conformed mesh, go to the File Explorer folder of the Unreal Engine project.
In the saved folder, the obj file of the mesh that was used for the solve will include the
name ScannedMesh.
In the folder with the name of the metahuman identity asset, the obj file that includes
the name conformal face mesh will be the conformed mesh of the metahuman identity and it will
be of metahuman topology.
The next step of this workflow is to bring these meshes into your choice of 3D software
to inspect them.
And from there, you can refit any details that were lost during the solve back onto the conformed
mesh.
Let's jump into Autodesk Maya and inspect the meshes.
In a new Maya scene, I have added the scanned and conformed mesh obj files.
Over here in the Outliner, this is the scanned mesh, which is what was used for the solve.
Over here, I'm going to unhide the conformed mesh that was generated from the solve.
Since this is already of metahuman topology, we can use this to refit accents that may
have been lost during the solve while preserving the existing polygon flow.
Let's do a quick review before we move on.
The conformed mesh can be used to bring back volume and large accents that may have been
lost in the solve while preserving the existing polygon flow.
Just ensure to mask and protect important polygon flow regions, such as the eyes and
inside of the mouth, when projecting details onto the conformed mesh.
Once the metahuman topology has been refitted to the scanner sculpt, this can be used with
the mesh to metahuman workflow using the template mesh option to generate a metahuman identity
that will be solved based on geometry.
This method will give us a more precise match and better joint positioning for lower LODs.
In the next section, we will review the mesh to metahuman workflow using the template mesh
option before moving on to the next hands-on exercise where we go through the steps of
this workflow.